what's up dogs and homies and chicks and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
and dicks we hit eighty thousand
subscribers and we use every offensive
name to call somebody along the way yeah
cuz that's what the channel is all about
offending of ending people and then they
go others so edgy crazy oh my god
they're willing to say things no one
else is willing to say I think bo
burnham says but like really like
offending people is like not edgy at all
anymore because I know that's all
anybody wants to do that's a thing and
that's when something's actually
entertained like being edgy is not edgy
I agree anyway yeah as I look at our
numbers right now we are 80,000 498
subscribers whoa we've been jumping up
like three to five hundred subscribers a
day for the past couple months damn
that's really in thanks to us cuz of how
awesome we are dead nope oh alright
kidding well if you want to hear it's
the OU's guy it's thanks to you guys
because you guys upset it before it's
eighty thousand subscribers you are the
subscribers yeah I mean you guys
dedicate your time and attention you
because now you I mean we're just
talking to no one like two crazy people
like two crazy people thanks for helping
us to not be insane and even though the
videos are mainly us talking to each
other we can't just accept the fact that
there's not a camera pointed at us when
we talk about stuff so thank you guys
most places I go I'm filmed yeah mm-hmm
usually when they go to the bathroom
that's not know oh yes that's not the
place for that mmm when I first went to
take a [ __ ] I halfway through the [ __ ] I
realized I'm pushing out a baby oh who
then from there my child was born that
Johnny Depp regression that winds up a
lot of disturbing implications well how
old was he when he first shat then I
don't know I don't know